so jumping in like i have a few other
questions before we get to why i get to
talk to you today um if someone has
actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
ah gee that that's an interesting
question
um
i think it would depend who the person
is
um uh how old they are
uh uh that kind of thing
uh
i i i can tell you when you know when i
meet somebody who hasn't seen the west
wing but wants to start watching the
west wing uh i'll i'll ask them to start
with the second season uh because it
took like the first season for me to
figure out uh how to write the show uh
if they want to see
uh
a movie uh i've written
uh it becomes a little trickier
that's a good question like i said i
think my answer is it depends on who's
asking
sure um you obviously are on a level
where if you said i want to make this
movie i would imagine a lot of people
might express interest so this the ques
i asked this question of a lot of people
and i'm not sure what your answer is
going to be if you could get the
financing to make literally anything you
want to make what would you make and why
listen right as we sit here
for the first time in a long time i
don't know what i'm writing next i i
don't have an idea for whatever is going
to be next
so
uh
you know i i don't have a passion
project that's been in my pocket all
these years that i've uh that i've
wanted made
uh so
i'll have to let you know when i get an
idea
uh whatever ended up happening to that
houdini project the musical that you
were gonna do with danny elfman uh
danny elfman turned into steven schwartz
um so i started working with uh with
steven schwartz i was so excited uh
about that
and it was a complicated project uh
and basically
uh
we just couldn't steven and i couldn't
find a place to connect on the page i i
was writing something from different
from what he was writing and uh we just
couldn't make it work
uh the same sort of thing but uh ocean
of storms that you
uh maybe worked on with bet you know
with warren which i don't know if you
want to talk about
yeah it's the movie warren and i have
been making for close to 30 years
um
uh i i was invited to
i was a punk kid uh out here
uh to
adapt
my play a few good men into the movie uh
a few good men uh and he had seen it and
he was impressed with it and i was
invited to a dinner uh at his house
uh i mean this would have been in in
1991
um
and was terrified it was warren beatty
and the kind of people who hang out with
warren beatty
um
and
i just happened to mention something i
think it was the first time i was
speaking up all night
i happened to mention something about
the moon and space
uh and
nasa um and my interest in it
and he took me aside and he said did you
say that on purpose did you say that
because you know that i have this
project and i honestly i didn't know
what he was talking about um and what he
had was an old script called uh ocean of
storms where there was
one scene in it that he liked and he
felt that the rest didn't work and and
he wanted to start over
so
um
i can't tell you how many
sandwiches at a deli uh warren and i
have had about ocean of storms um and
i'll always love it because it was the
thing that started this three-decade
friendship uh with this giant
will
so the script's done or is it not done
no
no
no it was never started
i want to drill down on this so bad but
i got to move on um obviously i think we
might have spoken for the social network
many years ago um and the fact is that
that's a masterpiece it's a brilliant
piece of writing with i mean everything
about that movie is phenomenal right um
and
in the last 11 years facebook has
morphed into something completely
different we all know what i'm getting
at um have you and david actually talked
about
in a serious way
continuing the story you know 10 years
later and looking at the ramifications
of what has happened well it's something
i've thought about a lot uh and i i've
mentioned it uh to david
um
[Music]
and uh
i i think i'll leave it there
um i i don't want to make any news uh uh
with regard to a social network
follow-up except to agree with you
uh that uh there's more story
oh absolutely and i would love it for
you to be you and david to tell it i
love nothing more yeah um so moving into
why i actually get to talk to you uh i
really want to start with a sincere
congratulations on the film um i think
one of the really the smart things i
think not that i'm smart but like the
way that you took these real true events
and just happened to have them all
happen over one week
i
love uh compressing time and
space
i love those
that claustrophobic almost play-like
feeling
uh so there were these three things that
happened these three uh big events in in
their life
the the accusation that lucy was a
communist um uh the fact that lucy was
pregnant at a time when a woman could
not possibly be pregnant on television
uh and the third was
desi showing up on the cover of
confidential magazine a gossip rag with
another woman in the headline does he's
wild night out
uh and
i thought well you know i'm not
perverting history uh or
or um
uh defaming these people
if i take those three events and make
them happen during one week compress
time uh and have the whole thing take
place during one production week of i
love lucy monday table read to friday
audience taping
so
uh that's what i did dramatists get to
do that
yeah i should have said three and not
four i like making myself look stupid no
no no no it's okay uh you do not you do
not look stupid
um so i'm fascinated by the editing
process because it's ultimately where it
all comes together um this is now your
third film that you've directed what
have you learned as you've been
progressing in the editing room that
perhaps you know could you sort of talk
about because it's a different beast
than writing
uh it is um and the first thing i'll
talk about is alan baumgarten who's
directed all three films uh i'm sorry
who's edited all three films that uh
that i've directed uh and he is
fantastic
i love the editing process and even
before i started directing
as uh as the executive producer as the
showrunner on on the television that i
did
uh there would be a director's cut
um and then there would be a tommy
schlammy cut uh after that and finally
it would get to me and by the time it
got to me it was in very good shape so
there wasn't a lot to do but i still
loved sitting with the editor um and
saying can you afraid let's shave four
frames off that and you know get to the
line faster um i'll you know let's let's
use the two shot here uh that kind of
thing uh so i really do love the editing
process
uh with this film in particular did you
have a much longer first cut or was it
pretty much
i guess let me let me stop there
no uh not much longer and there's only
uh
there's one line
that is on the edit that is on the
cutting room floor i i can't think of
anything else that was cut from the film
uh so it got shorter with tightening um
uh i think probably the first cut
was 11 minutes longer than our final cut
um but it was just taking air out of
scenes
uh you made this film i believe in 38
days which is not a lot of time to make
a film
to make any film let alone this kind of
a film let alone during covet
all of that so my my question for you is
uh talk a little bit about like was
there any point during the shoot that
you're like i don't know if we're gonna
be able to pull this off in the time
frame we have
you know there wasn't
um uh uh there wasn't
i would say before the shoot
uh i was thinking 38 days how can we
possibly uh do this in 38 days
but um another person who's been with me
on all three films is stuart besser
our line producer
and he's the one responsible for
for the schedule
and uh
not only didn't i ever feel pressured uh
at time pressure during that time i felt
other kinds of pressure not only didn't
i feel time pressure
uh
but there were some days that almost
felt luxurious
uh uh like wow we can
we can take our time here we can
rehearse longer uh maybe i can send the
crew home an hour early
uh so
that it's uh and i credit stuart with
that stuart and a great crew
i was also gonna say i would imagine
that all the actors that you brought in
like if you're working if these actors
and everyone are working for you i think
everyone's bringing their a game it's
not you know what i mean yes they are i
think these actors bring their a game no
matter who they're working with and that
is a big part of it when the actors come
to work ready to work uh and they're not
learning the scene in the makeup trailer
uh um then it's
it makes the days a lot better uh you
know you're you're getting
getting good stuff by the second take
i also loved the flash forward uh flash
forwards if you will and um and the fact
that you have ronnie cox in the movie is
like a plus casting so i really do want
to know how many how long did it take
you when you're working with ronnie to
bring up total recall or robot
um i i can tell you that it took the
crew uh a matter of seconds uh to bring
a total recall
i mean seriously though i would spend my
entire day being like chris farley so
you remember when you were in that movie
yeah
uh and and i am that way with a lot of
actors
um
uh
including ronnie
uh but
getting into actually the flash forwards
how did you craft that idea of putting
the flash forwards in the movie
i needed something i needed a way to
tell the audience right off the bat
uh
that
i i love lucy was simply a different
animal from every television show we're
familiar with today in terms of its
popularity
uh of 60 million people watching the
show uh of department stores changing
the night that they were open late
because of the show of
a measurable drop in the amount of water
being used during the show because no
one was going to the bathroom no one was
cooking anything uh in the kitchen
uh
and and i needed a way uh to convey that
and
uh so i thought of this idea and once
you do that you know you can't just do
it once and leave it alone it'll become
an exposition machine um so
i i needed to thread them throughout the
film uh and
uh
and have them kind of join up with the
story at the very end
i also love um man i can keep on
praising you but i the thing about the
the thing about this is that i never
thought of the line honey i'm home
in the way that i now think about it
after seeing this movie um and you know
um so could you sort of talk about like
although i'm not 100 sure that line
is like because i heard this rumor
doesn't matter um that maybe it wasn't a
rumor that he never said it yes like
javier was saying that and i'm like i
don't know i don't know if that's true
people mistake no no he uh in the first
season alone does he says lucy i'm home
17 times right okay that's
um lucy you got some explaining to do
which to having desi never said uh on
the show i'm not sure how it became
uh it's
it's era's version of a meme but uh but
it did
i
but but lucy i'm home
uh
i was driving in my car which is
also what i do during the climbing the
walls uh agonizing period um i try to
find a
straight piece of road a freeway where
i'm not gonna have to think about
turning um
and uh
i try to start arguments with myself uh
to see if i can get a scene going
and what happened was
and just to set this up we've got lucy
um who yearns for domesticity
uh
and
it just occurred to me you know the most
iconic line from the show is lucy i'm
home
i
i can load that up
uh i i i can emphasize home
in the story i can write a speech
uh that you know happens on the sound
stage at 2am with bill and vivian
where she talks about uh it being like
uh a story you tell a fairy tale you
tell a little girl where a witch casts a
spell
that the um she'll be adored by the man
she loves as long as she stays uh on
this patch of ground and she talks about
how uh you know she did the she did out
of lucy to save her marriage she thought
the construction department they'll
build us this little apartment and
that's where we'll live
um uh and i'm driving in my car thinking
about all this and the very same smile
that lucy gets on her face of the irony
just literally stopping her in her
tracks in front of an audience of desi
walking in the door and saying lucy i'm
home i got that smile uh on my face i
knew
what the end of the movie was gonna be
and once you have that you can write
toward it
on that known amount of time i really
hope at some point in the near future i
get to have a longer conversation with
you i hope so too thanks a lot for this
one i really appreciate it thank you so
much have a great day
you